this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later on hey 42 here the
concept of a soul is one of those things
you probably instinctively understand
but you might have trouble explaining to
someone who'd never heard of it before
if that's the case don't worry you
aren't the only one we humans have been
trying to figure out exactly what our
souls are
for literally thousands of years
during that time countless ideas have
been put forward by various religions
and who's who of humanity's greatest
thinkers
whilst no single definition exists to
this day
most people agree that the soul is a
non-physical and
possibly immortal part of us that
essentially makes each of us who we are
considering it's something we can't see
or measure in any way it's kind of
interesting that almost every culture in
history has believed in a human soul of
some shape or form for whatever reason
we seem to be predisposed to accept
there's more to us than just meat and
bones
the question is
is there
now i want to take a moment to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s and it's always been
an upsetting experience if you're in the
same boat then you're not alone did you
know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now
and do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trusts them for their hair loss
prevention medication
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash 42 or click the link in
the description below to receive 50
off your first order don't miss out
plenty of people have attempted to find
out exactly that over the years
take american physician duncan mcdougall
for example who in 1901 conducted what
would go on to become arguably one of
the most famous experiments in history
for all the wrong reasons
mcdougall's idea was pretty simple he
reasoned that if the soul existed it
must be a physical thing like every
other part of our bodies if that was the
case
it must have a mass
and if the soul had mass mcdougall could
weigh it so far so logical
but there was one slight problem with
this groundbreaking idea in order to
successfully conduct the experiment
mcdougall was going to have to get his
hands on a nice fresh soul to pop on his
scale it seemed he'd run up against a
kind of scientific catch-22 in order to
prove the soul existed he'd first need a
soul to weigh but if he had assault away
he wouldn't need to prove they existed
the solution mcdougall found to this
apparent paradox was actually kind of
ingenious
if a little ethically questionable you
see he realized that weighing a soul was
actually pretty easy all you had to do
was stick a human on a scale the hard
part would be figuring out how much of
that person's total weight came from
their soul and how much came from all
the meaty bits they're made up of so any
ideas how he did it
well mcdougall was a christian and like
any christian worth his communion wafer
he knew that when we die our souls leave
our bodies and head off in search of the
big party in the sky all mcdougall had
to do was weigh someone in the process
of dying if their body suddenly got
lighter at the moment of death it must
be caused by the soul leaving the body
admittedly the logistics of this
apparently straightforward idea were a
little tricky in order to complete the
experiment in a timely manner mcdougall
was going to need a bunch of test
subjects prepared to hop on his scale
and immediately die luckily for
mcdougall and unluckily for basically
everyone else tuberculosis was a huge
killer in the us at the time and as far
as diseases went tb was practically
tailor-made for his soul experiment
not only was it pretty obvious when
sufferers were nearing the end the
disease also made them incredibly weak
and feeble meaning they were unlikely to
mess up mcdougall's delicate
measurements in their death throws the
next problem came in convincing local
terminally ill tb sufferers to spend
their final moments lying on mcdougall's
industrial size scale rather than
you know saying goodbye to their loved
ones
but he must have been a pretty
persuasive guy because eventually he
managed to sign up six people to do
exactly that four were suffering from tb
one from diabetes and one was just
generally in a bit of a bad way
considering their various states of ill
health
it wasn't long before one of them began
to show signs that death was approaching
mcdougall didn't waste any time within a
matter of minutes the first test subject
was in position on the scale the man
took a frankly inconsiderate 3.5 hours
to actually die from that point
but mcdougall didn't let impatience get
to him he watched a reading on the scale
like a hawk noting that the subject lost
weight at a steady rate in the lead up
to death
most likely through sweat dying from
tuberculosis is hard work but then
at the exact moment of death something
miraculous happened the scale suddenly
dipped as though a small weight had been
lifted from the test subject well the
corpse mcdougall was certain he'd
accounted for every variable
which
could only mean one thing his experiment
had been a success he'd just weighed the
human soul
you might be familiar with the results
he got too
21.3 grams the figure remains famous to
this day it was the title of a 2003 film
starring sean penn it features in the
lyrics of several songs and the plots of
plenty of novels including dan brown's
the lost symbol it even cropped up in a
recent episode of ted lasso
unfortunately this is probably a good
time to point out that there are a few
small problems with mcdougall's
legendary experiment and when i say a
few small problems what i really mean is
that calling it a scientific experiment
should be seen as a personal insult to
every scientist who's ever lived you see
pretty much every aspect of the
methodology mcdougall employed was
flawed his sample size was small his
measuring equipment wasn't particularly
sensitive
and he had no way of accurately
pinpointing his subject's time of death
something that often isn't as obvious as
you might expect
even worse during the experiments he
carried out on his six subjects
mcdougall only actually saw the famous
21 gram decrease in weight on one
occasion
the other experiments were kind of a
shambles in one mcdougall's test subject
had the audacity to die before the scale
was properly calibrated
and in another an angry mob stormed into
the lab and prevented the experiment
from taking place altogether in the
other three experiments mcdougall got a
different result every time one of the
subjects gained weight on death and
another lost a little before apparently
putting it back on again if you're
wondering how exactly mcdougall
explained these inconsistent results he
didn't he just ignored everything that
didn't support his hypothesis
now in his defense he did state that his
results would need to be replicated in
the future if they're to be widely
accepted and as you can probably imagine
that's never happened
today the idea that the soul can be
weighed has very much been left behind
by mainstream science in fact for the
most part the scientific community has
given up on the idea of a soul
altogether and the reason for that can
be summed up in a single word
neuroscience
in the past hundred years or so and
particularly in the last two or three
decades neuroscience has begun to
uncover the secrets of the human brain
at a truly remarkable rate in that time
we've found that many of the things we
once considered to be firmly in the
domain of the soul
things like falling in love and thinking
deep thoughts about life the universe
and everything all seem to be
explainable by physical processes taking
place in the brain and if everything
about who we are can be explained by
measurable observable processes that
take place in our brains and bodies then
it's hard to see where the soul fits in
having said that the game isn't quite up
for the soul just yet because whilst
neuroscience has taught us a huge amount
about our brains it turns out there's
one thing it so far hasn't been able to
explain and if i'm being honest it's
kind of a biggie consciousness itself
you see
despite millennia of philosophical
pondering and decades of rigorous
scientific research
we humans are singularly unable to
explain how or why we're self-aware it's
undoubtedly the biggest unanswered
question in all of neuroscience and our
understanding of the subject is so poor
we don't even really have a good
definition of what consciousness
actually is in the first place as
frustrating as this might be you have to
appreciate the irony the human brain is
currently completely unable to
understand exactly how the human brain
works then again as scientist and author
lyle watson once said if the brain was
so simple we could understand it we
would be so simple we couldn't
well played lyle
well played so
whilst many a neuroscientist will
happily tell you you don't have a soul
what they can't tell you is what it is
you do have that makes you
well
you
an eeg or mri scan can show us which
parts of the brain are active whilst we
make a cup of tea or smell a rose
but consciousness itself
is different we can't see it on a scan
and it doesn't reside in a single region
of the brain we know that because it
often sticks around even when whole
sections of the brain are damaged or
even removed entirely hannibal lecter
style to say all that in its simplest
terms
science can't explain why you watching
this video are resident in your own mind
it's easy to assume that
self-consciousness is just an inevitable
byproduct of intelligence but that
doesn't seem to be the case after all
computers can be far more intelligent
than humans at least in certain ways
and they aren't self-aware
some scientists believe they never will
be either regardless of the advances we
make with ai
now before any angry neuroscientists
start complaining in the comments i'm
watching you
i should point out that the fact we
can't explain consciousness
isn't in itself an argument that souls
exist
the truth is as of today there's no
compelling scientific evidence
supporting the idea that we humans come
bundled with an inbuilt non-physical
immortal soul
that might sound like a bit of a blow
but if it does turn out to be true at
least we should be used to it by now
science has an annoying habit of coming
along and informing us humans that we
aren't quite as special as we like to
think we are
we used to believe the earth was at the
center of the universe
until some bloke called aristarchus of
samos ruined everything by pointing out
that the earth actually seemed to be
orbiting the sun
and darwin rocked up more than 2 000
years later to bust a myth that we
humans were somehow separate from the
rest of the animal kingdom it may well
be that science slaying the soul is the
next step on what has been a long and
often uncomfortable journey for our
species
but for many people none of this matters
in the slightest
their belief in the existence of the
soul is exactly that a belief
it doesn't require evidence or proof
and therefore science's opinion on the
matter
isn't really relevant
at least to them
as for which side of the debate you come
down on only you can decide thanks for
watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you